Google's CEO says he canceled the
meeting meant to address a controversial
memo for safety reasons the 10 page
document written by former employee
James to more criticize the tech giant's
diversity initiatives it included
statements that women are more neurotic
than men the more wrote that this may
contribute to the lower number of
females in the tech industry Google's
CEO sundar pichai sent a company-wide
email explaining why he called off the
town hall meeting to address that memo
he said the company needs to step back
and create a better set of conditions
for us to have a discussion Megan Smith
is the former u.s. chief technology
officer during the Obama administration
and a former VP at Google Megan welcome
are you surprised by all that you're
hearing here now recently about Google
and was your experience similar to what
you've what you've heard yeah you know
this isn't specific to Google but that
sort of the tech industry has is it's an
extraordinary industry it's so fun to
work in but a lot of young women of all
races men of color face a lot of
challenges because of these kind of
insidious perspectives that are around
did you hear people say stuff like the
shirt you did yeah and you know you hear
it all day or I got wake up death five
thousand cuts you know it's just all
around but there's also wonderful
aspects and so how do you know the
leadership the sender is shown here is
important to make sure we discern
between you know and get people like
this to not be able to inflict these
kinds of opinions which are not based on
science this is solvable one of the
greatest challenges that that people
face are if for example you know when we
watch television we're seeing all this
bias and children's TV it's fifteen to
one boy programmers to girl programmers
we just see that and so teachers are
hidden figures we don't know you have a
lunar module beautiful over here people
don't know about Margaret Hamilton she
led the software for that you know women
and men have eyes on technology and in
her country and around the world which
is why movies like that is so important
why do you think that there is a lack of
female representation in technology well
why well they come in to technology you
need a couple things you need to know
the people like you do it which is part
of this you know telling this truth
stories you know Ada Lovelace is the
original creator of algorithms in the
1800's no one knows that a woman or
Grace Hopper created computer languages
your women did this you need to try it
so we got to get this in their schools
nine out of ten parents want coding
taught at school you know we took
freshman biology let's all take coding
and let's have boot camps and other
things we're on a tech jobs tour right
now we're gonna be in West Virginia in
Kentucky this week we're just in San
Francisco all over country getting
people and we have six hundred thousand
jobs open in the United States right now
they pay 50% more than the average
American salary they're fun you know we
want more people in tech and we got to
get rid of the biases that make people
feel uncomfortable and leave the
industry well it appears that the CEO of
Google send our pitch I agrees he wrote
an email to employees saying quote
portions of the memo violate our code of
conduct to suggest a group of our
colleagues have traits that make them
less biologically suited to that work is
offensive and not okay did you yourself
ever experience any kind of eyes when
you work there not so much yes I think I
think you feel it in Jessica yes and all
of the elements that jobs that I've been
in you know even in my own family my
father was a my grandfather was a
fabulous engineer he worked on at u.s.
steel he built the highways in Indiana
when I went to engineering school he
said to me why would she want to do that
right so they couldn't see his
granddaughter doing this that Google's
wonderful sundar was one of the greatest
people I've ever worked with you know
and many of my colleagues there Susan
Wojcicki wrote a wonderful piece who's
the CEO of YouTube about her daughter
asking you know is it really true mom
it's not true it's just not true but
these are old ideas that persist and
people bring them up and we have to
really not faint we have to help these
young engineers evolve out and they're
seeing an echo chamber because of the
imbalance they imagine somehow their
ideas correct it's not
well James damar who wrote that memo
we're talking about here says he was
wrongfully terminated for what he was
told perpetuating gender stereotypes and
of those polled more than half of Google
employees say he shouldn't have been
fired what do you think should he have
been you know I I'm not going to comment
on what they did
individually but you know I'm on the
board at MIT and Chuck vest who was
present in the 90s there was an amazing
survey done in the research area at lab
space grants you know promotions
women versus men an academic field and
he wrote at the head of that he said I I
always thought it was part myth in part
true now I know the better fact that
it's almost all reality and so this is
real people face the security
discrimination and but we can solve it
and I think I'm you know really proud of
what Google is doing you know to step
back and really work on that there
they've been doing this for years you're
seeing Intel and slack and other
companies really stepping forward moving
the primary not know I think you're
doing there I think they can do more all
of the companies but what's been nice is
to see leadership of people taking this
you know this is in their top 20
priorities let's move it to the top
three to five because want to field the
whole American team on our hardest
problems right and and these are hard
problems also as we get into artificial
intelligence and machine learning you
mean we need to make sure that we're not
running a discrimination into the
algorithms so we want everybody in Megan
Smith thank you very much fascinating
discussion